Hello, you know you got to pay for that right?
Hey, cmon'
Not okay!
Looks like we got ourselves an X-Men fan.
Maybe a quarter of it happened, but not like
this.
In the real world people die.
I don't want to talk about it, Logan, just
stop
Be careful,
I need the girl, what girl?
Go get her
No, No, No.
Holy F*ck
She's like you, very much like you.
I am not whatever it is you think I am.
She needs our help, someone will come along.
Someone has come along.
This is what life looks like, people who love
each other.
Make a home.
You should take a moment, feel it.
You still have time.
Two days on the road, only one meal and hardly
any sleep.
She's 11, I'm F*cking 90!
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie new Logan trailer
we got a break this down is going to be so
awesome.
I love the fact that he's actually reading
some Chris Claremont era X-Men comics we'll
talk about that but there is a new round of
the Deadpool giveaway it's a $20 comixology
gift card.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Wolverine related comment on this
video be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything.
So the big thing in this trailer is the introduction
of Laura X 23 from the comics who's a Wolverine
clone and you see like a lot of things happening
in this that seem to imply Mr. sinister stuff
that's happening the comics that is holding
up our Chris Claremont I'm actually having
trouble pinpointing them but they just imply
savage land just all genetic engineering Mr.
sinister type stuff so just blows your mind
that he's reading, comic books, one, but it
also helps sort of pinpointed in the timeline
like they're implying that all these adventures
happen.
Somebody wrote comics in the real world about
their adventures in this is happening.
After that we know a little bit about how
she enters the felt like the context for what's
going on here.
So the villains that you're seeing here are
actually the reverse.
The main villain's like their two main villain
series see Richard E Grant is playing Dr.
Xander Rice who actually debuted in the X
23, comic way way back to the leader of the
reverse here is played by Donald Pierce there
just a group that's dedicated to the destruction
of the X-Men, so the way they're explaining
it.
Richard Ygritte like a lot of people wondered
if he was going to be Mister Sinister that's
not who he is he is somebody from the comics
but in the continuity in the comics he's the
son of someone who worked on the original
weapon next program so you have to imagine
that, during days of Future past, they sort
of fix the timeline, but now there be no back
to being really old again and you have the
reverse who been hunting down and killing
X-Men, so based on the synopsis the Hugh Jackman
revealed a little while ago.
He's been hiding out on the Mexican border
trying to help Prof. X and then along comes
this little girl that he learns about, so
he doesn't know anything about her, but then
he sees that she's basically a piece of him
like literally a piece of him because she's
a clone, any sort of confronted with himself
because she's exactly like him.
So because this is the last Wolverine movie.
There's sort of this eulogy for his character
sort of sending him off we'll talk about that
in the second like the future of the actual
Wolverine character, but it's meant to be
a good buy for him as he sort of looks in
the mirror and is confronted with himself
in this young girl, so everybody that saw
the first 40 minutes of the movie said it
was amazing.
It's not like any X-Men movies you seen before
in the same way the Deadpool wasn't like an
X-Men movie that you've seen before and there
are some similarities with the way they introduced
the X 23 character if you remember the beginning
of Deadpool they show that scene where he
basically destroys strikers lab is he breaks
out of their version of the weapon next program.
It's sort of the same type of introduction
with the X 23 character which was also kind
of the same way that the Wolverine character
was introduced way back in the original weapon
next program you remember this is rated R.
So just so much more hard-core, so it is the
most brutal introduction of this awesome little
girl, so it can be so much fun.
But the reapers themselves do share a lot
of ties with the hellfire club.
So even though.
This is sort of like a smaller self-contained
type of movie you'll be seeing a lot of things
that refer to other parts of the X-Men movies
just little bit, but the toner just like so
different that that's why they set this off
by itself.
That's why feel like such a different type
of movie but I love the introduction here
like you have no contact you see a little
girl in a gas station just grabbing stuff
because she's hungry almost goes full, Wolverine
on the gas station attendant till Logan walks
in and stops are short not okay kid grab some
cigars on the way.
So this seems like it's a little bit later
in the film because they do have a relatively
linear progression where you meet the X 23
character you understand how she meets the
Wolverine character and then that sort of
sets off the relationship in the rest of the
film, but if you never read the X-Men comics
essentially she has all the same powers as
Wolverine remember she's a genetic clone is
just that she has two claws in her hands instead
of the three.
She has one in her feet, but I don't know
if they did that in the movie or not, that
might be some WTF surprise, but speaking of
powers it seems like because Prof. X is in
his 90s his powers are waning to just like
Wolverine's powers of regeneration are slowly
waiting.
So even though Wolverine is functionally immortal
because of his healing factor there been at
least 10 times in the comics that they have
killed him off through various means sometimes
it's using magic sometimes it's another version
of Wolverine.
Nobody knows how to kill, Wolverine like another
version of Wolverine from the multi-verse
are from a different point in the timeline.
So Patrick Stewart's I just love that they
let him be in this movie is perfect for the
old man Logan motif they're going for even
though.
This is literally old man Logan the comic
book most WTF Wolverine story ever.
You should definitely read it.
If you have a chance but fair warning is pretty
crazy the way they explain how the other X-Men
die and because it's Marvel comics involves
all of the characters not just the characters
that Fox controls you get the sense that he's
been very reluctant to fight for a long time
but the arrival of Laura X 23 gives him something
to fight for see you get the crazy intense
holdout moment here, where he just goes crazy
on everyone, but it's so much more fun watching
her do it to but she jumps over his back here
you definitely see what looks like the death
of Prof. X.
So it looks like this is his grave that they're
standing over, just sort of eulogizing him
and then a lot of people are wondering if
this scene here where they don't show their
faces just been a Wolverine all cut up sitting
against the tree might be the death of Wolverine
that could be the case but I have a feeling
that the can end this movie in a way that
will bookend the character without completely
throwing him in the fridge like the neck in
the fridge the Wolverine character.
There will always be X-Men movies with the
Wolverine character in some form or another,
but I think because it's rated R there little
more free to be ambiguous about the ending.
Like maybe he's not coming back.
Maybe is going to be dead than they would
in like a PG-13 traditional popcorn movie
that you see during the summer.
So, I am totally on board for these WTF comic
book movies just as long as it is in keeping
with the tone of the character like you could
probably do a rated R Batman movie.
But I don't feel like there's a version of
a rated R Superman movie that just doesn't
feel in keeping with the tone of the character
so I'm expecting the main X-Men films will
stay PG-13 but if they do more Wolverine movies
in the future if they reboot the character
or they do it Deadpool crossover like Ryan
Reynolds is trying to get them to do that
will definitely be rated R, but we gotta talk
about X 23 in the future of the Wolverine
character so there's a creative reboot happening
of Fox right now what I feel like they'll
do is the just kind of quietly keep the Wolverine
character on the shelf for a little bit and
then will recast a new actor that is age-appropriate
with the time.
But they're doing the X-Men films and so the
next big X-Men movie the rumor dark Phoenix
movie is supposed to take place during the
90s they would cast a much younger version
of Wolverine if he was can a cameo in that
but is still a couple years away.
So it's all speculation right now.
Let me know what you want them to do with
the Wolverine character assuming the Hugh
Jackman doesn't come back but I do think it's
totally possible that he would come back for
some Deadpool crossover even if he's just
playing himself like a some funny joke like
he was a mask in the first movie.
Maybe they do an actual Hugh Jackman cameo
in the second movie, so the always be a lot
of like Hugh Jackman, Ryan Reynolds Deadpool
stuff even if he's not playing Wolverine looks
awesome.
I'm so happy like I know it seems like it's
been a while, but things are just getting
started now all the comic book movies are
gonna start posting a whole bunch more trailers
will start seeing more footage from everything
that's coming in the next couple months especially
now that the Super Bowl is getting ready to
happen.
So if there's anything you guys want me to
do bonus videos for for the Logan character
or for X 23 or the X-Men movies are Deadpool
just let me know in the comments is gonna
be so much awesome stuff happening this year
is going to be a great year for comic book
movies.
What can happen next is I have some game of
thrones that I'll post.
So just look out for that what you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to learn
what's going on with the new Spider-Man movie
and you can click here to learn what's going
on with to thank you so much watching everybody
high five I'll see you guys tonight!